with a core part of the hr application
just to let you know you can enter
questions for vendra in the
q a panel
chat to all panelists
and we want to start before we start the
session with a quick poll
and this is
to ask you how much experience you have
and how you're feeling today so let me
launch that poll for you
if you're watching in the streaming
service please put your answers in the
comments
and give you about 20 seconds to do that
and we'll close the poll in about three
seconds
so just to give rivendra a feel for the
audience
uh it's a pretty even distribution of
people um
about a third who are still in
school and
about a third who have more than five
years experience so it covers range
and it's good to see that almost
everybody is doing well or doing okay we
asked that about
how you're doing because
we know that the stress of the pandemic
with surges coming rising and falling
and
lockdown's coming and going
can be a stressful time so
i wanted to check in with you on that
and
with that i am going to um create over
rugbendra allow me to
[Music]
give him
control of the screen
sure i can i haven't got the controller
to share my screen
yeah you're getting it right now
all right
cool so let me share my screen
okay
is my screen visible to all of you guys
yes it is
cool okay uh
today
i'm gonna show you actually uh about two
things before before anything else let
me introduce myself to you
give me one second please
i skipped very deep inside
this light about me
okay uh
myself ragweed
currently i am working in one of the
fortunate companies and i am working as
a lead full stack development engineer
give me one moment guys
what are you just switching on the file
sorry about that
so currently uh like i am also managing
a team of 68 members in the company
where i work
and also i am doing a i'm also active
part of development group in that in the
team and i have conducted multiple
trainings across various platforms
starting from simply learn upgrade
newton school great learning zero wired
and other tech lines and my rating tied
late predominantly i've been on the ir
side
so i'm also part of this
simply learn where i take a lot of faces
like phase one to face like all the
faces i take sessions
and uh today i'll be taking you through
the actual kind of
uh walkthrough of how things works in
simply learn okay that's the agenda for
today and i will show you what is lms
and i'll show you the structure and
everything
and finally i'll be taking you through
the one of the demo where i'll be
showing you
actual
coding what i'm going to do in the class
which i built for the past after that i
was sitting to write the entire code and
i have written some of the some piece of
it uh i'll be showing it to you how in
the real time i'll teach it and also so
everything we're gonna see
so
let me open on notepad plus plus
so agenda for today i'll keeping it as i
wish i'll be talking about lms portal
that's what that's what uh we'll you
will be using through the course
then you will be logging into the
different phases you will be
talking about a lot of different stuff
and i'll explain this first i'll explain
the structure first then i'll explain
the project so that's how i'll be taking
it first elements and explain and then
i'll explain all the faces
we have totally five phases i'll explain
one of the faces in detail so i'll take
any phase maybe one or four three
is
in detail
and i'll explain about the
employee
fetch
say
application it's a very simple
application but there's a lot of code
written behind that here i'll be talking
about em there is a ui
which i'll be showing you with angular
and it gets the data on the back end and
i have the back end which
return in
spring boot
as the layer to expose all the leaves
and i'll also be talking will be i've
used spring data jpi here
data
get the data and i've used
my
sql
for
database here okay wherein i get
all the
data
for my ui okay
this is the kind of structure i'm going
to follow today so bear with me i have a
lot of content to show it to you guys
okay
let me log into the lms i'm sorry forgot
to log in and log in in a moment and
i'll shoot him with you
all right
so first of all uh you'll be i'll be
talking about this lms thing
wherein this course is all about the
full star development and i'll be
talking through this
here this program contains five
different phases okay first i'll show
you here then i'll again open a notepad
and explain them individually in detail
okay
so this particular course as
first of all we welcome you to the
course by introducing you the very basic
concepts of full struct development then
we'll be taking you through the
oops and java concept concepts and also
data structures and algorithms which
which are extremely important for
clearing the interviews so and also next
phase would be
becoming a back-end expert in this phase
we'll be covering more on the java side
okay wherein i would say we will make
you sure that out those how does things
actually work we all know spring we all
know spring boot we always bring nbc
stuff like that those are the buzzwords
people generally use it okay and
how do they really work under the hood
okay that's where these sessions like
this phase will be very helpful for you
guys
okay
and also we have the frameworks wherein
we'll be learning about all the
frameworks and then we have front end
and the devops cycle okay let's cycle
why i'm showing this first before i take
in detail
uh like
detail about this courses because this
is the portal where you will have
most of the information stacked up this
would be a single source of truth okay
for you guys to refer every single time
so keep that in mind
and
in this let's say for example if you
want to go through today uh we have
session on something on to understand
how basic servlet works because if you
notice there is spring boot also with
spring mvc also we use a term called as
dispatcher servlet again that's a
servlet so we should we need to know
that basic understanding of how solid
works then only we can make sense of
okay if i say front controller or
dispatcher servlet how it works then
only we'll get more control on it right
so that's what i'm gonna tell you so
this course will be actually taking
about so after now you
this all the ui stuff now i'll take you
to the individual
details of this particular course okay
one second let me open that for you
right
so like i shown already there will be
five different phases in the phase one
we have this set this mini lessons
we'll be taking you to the java deep
dive and we'll be talking about building
blocks and
we'll be making sure that you are now
good enough to understand structures in
algorithm okay so maybe
my voice is not audible i think uh you
have to change your speaker i guess
this month other people are able to hear
me i guess right so they can hear me
right
yes i can yes i can
cool cool yeah i'll proceed further okay
i think one guy has a problem in his
voice i guess like speakers i asked him
to
check it out okay in the phase two we
have i will be going we'll be i'll be
taking you through this okay
all these phases i also teach
so that's the reason i know more in
depth about this i'll show you one
example also how this would be
in the second phase
basically i'll be talking about how to
develop web pages using servlets is
introduction i'll be giving it to you
then after learning that i'll be taking
you through the databases wherein how to
use
jdbc
because
to understand jpa and hibernates it's
extremely important for us to understand
how jdbc works because ibanez is a
framework which built on top of this
kind of kdbc because whatever jdbc does
operation directly through the back end
and connects java that's the inspiration
for the ibanez to come in ibrahimovic
are just a layer wherein it just talks
with multiple databases with its own
configuration so it's it becomes
extremely useful and important for a
developer to understand what jdb is all
about so i'll be showing this example
for you guys in in the with the help of
servlets as well as jsp okay
and then we i'll be moving on so for
every lesson we will have weekly
practice i would say projects okay i'll
be giving you projects
and after that every single phase end
i'll be giving you or me or whatever
whomsoever takes up we'll be giving you
one project okay for example this is the
project for the phase two
so that you guys will understand
the it's kind of
you learned all the blocks now you club
that and make a building okay you set
the basement you know all the bricks
where to keep now you keep everything in
the right places and make a building out
of it that's where face to come like
like this project comes in so we will i
will especially in my classes i'll keep
this in mind all the time whatever is
required i will definitely cover in this
phase throughout and make sure the
student is able to pick up those
knowledge and implement in here okay
then comes to phase three i'll be taking
you through detail about this or the
other one okay and in this one we'll be
learning about frameworks like
basic spring framework and it's it's
done and we have uh spring mvc we have
uh spring boot we have and also we'll be
learning about junit and we'll be
talking about
then micro services and i'll be giving
introduction about microservices kafka
and also
major majority components of along the
website like micro services right
because today world is all about micro
services you need to understand that how
architecture works what things goes in
here right so that's where things this
because this becomes very important
all right then
comes the phase four in the phase four
what we have we'll be creating the
front end application and again in this
one we'll be using the technology called
as angular okay again some people are
debatable that so why are we going to
learn
so
in this one basically we'll be learning
about how this entire angular things
works okay we'll be doing uh
understanding i'll be first of all
taking you through javascript html and
then i'll be taking you through the
angular because those basics are really
important to understand the framework
then at last we will be making you
uh like well versed with the
application right so i'm going to say
this uh
devops thing here enter devops starting
from amazon web services it can be
docker it can be communities all those
like knowledge will be taught here right
so by looking at this
you will come to know the structure of
it would look like okay now if i speak
about any one course in detail right
let's
take
sorry
phase three
you have seen this phase three right
this way then elaborate more
what i'm gonna teach in this phase three
in actual classes
in this phase three i'll be talking
about first about
how this spring architecture would look
like what our containers our jdbc
framework would look like how are we
replacing it with spring mbcs spring uh
with the help of spring with the law of
of course with the hebrew nets which we
already learned in the previous phase
then i'll be introducing you to how
spring boot works what difference
between them and how can we handle
exception in this spring boot and
building restful of services
and then
going forward from here onwards mostly
concept on the micro services
what is swagger how apache kafka works
how can we leverage that in the
microservices
and all those things so we will be
learning overall the entire stack about
how these micro services work in
what components we do need for the
lot of different pieces to come in okay
we'll be learning about this in this
detail in lesson two okay
this completes actually kind of entire
spring boot introduction
then it's development is not just about
coding it's also about in human testing
not complete testing unit testing
developer responsibility is all about
how
like
good is your code okay how error
error-free your code is how can we
verify that with the help of your test
cases so we'll be learning entire
week or entire day about june it because
it will be four hour classes on a
weekend so on saturday and sunday
we'll be taking you through this uh this
entire j5
and i'll be giving you mostly all the
different ways of writing unit test
cases
then going forward
we'll be learning about the
microservices using springboard and also
i'll be teaching you guys spring
security i'll be showing you step by
step okay and you leverage the spring
security right
and along with this you will do one
phase in project which will complete
your knowledge right so you'll be
building one website which will kind of
make a cherry on top of a kind of a
thing which will help you to build the
entire knowledge whatever you learned
and you know
end result so i'll be giving you enough
hints and enough architecture help here
i'll be mostly giving you the skeleton
where you have to just fill in details
how to do that i'll not spoon for
everything for sure i'll be at least
giving you skeleton how to do this
because i've already taught you before
this all the other topics
i will be giving you knowledge mostly on
how to build on top of it okay that's
what one detailed phase discussion
that's what we saw here actually i
explained you guys about this course for
which cc which we are seeing it here as
implementing frameworks using the devops
way okay this is all about the
the structure how it looks like okay now
i will be showing you guys one example
of
how this
you can consider it as this combination
of phase four and phase five or a
capsule project okay in capsule project
what we'll do is we will be
using all the knowledge of front and
back in everything and we'll
put him in one place okay
now
this is what i'm gonna build now okay
i'll show you how i built this
first of all we need to have we need to
write our
step one is to build our
spring boot
application
that's what i've done here look at this
i have actually
i have this employee controller here
okay so first of all your everything
starts from the okay let's go from
entity
i have entity called as employee
entity in the
java side is equivalent to table in the
back end okay
if you give this
and if i start the application spring
boot automatically creates a new table
for us okay you can ask me how
now in the sense if i open this
here i have all the configurations
if you see
this is the url database i'm giving this
is the credentials i'm giving and these
are the
i would say formatting things i'm given
here okay
by the presence of an entity
the moment i start the application
springboard will create this table
inside this
database that is
sim emp db okay so i'll just show you
once
uh okay
i'll close the open open one more time
i'll just say
connect
road at local
post
to
databases
use
sim
underscore emp underscore db
okay
show tables
if we see i have two different tables
because i have an employee entity and
also i have a student entity okay that's
why i have given here
droid table here
this automatically got created by the
spring boot for us because we have given
the configuration here okay this is my
database information you take care of
creating why
i have a ddl auto configuration that is
update every single time i stop and
start the application let's say there is
no table it will create everything let's
say there is a modification table it it
updates rather than the creating so this
configuration is again a big discussion
we can take it up in the actual uh i
would say the classes but for the sake
of demo proceed further
so here we have this
configuration with the help of this
these tables are created i will say
describe
employee
if you see i have id email id first name
and last name these are matching for
this
employee table okay it automatically
converts and puts underscore after every
word because it identifies n is capital
and we have a separate word coming up it
separates them and creates a
two different words and makes it like
joins with them with an underscore
that's how this looks okay
that's how the connection between the
employee table in the backend and
employee class in the
spring boot application look like now on
top of this we'll build the repository
okay now if we ask this what is his
reposition about which repository
actually helps us
let's say whatever default operations we
have maybe get
i would say get all employees get
employee
get employed by like we all we actually
have basic information whatever our
repository gives find find all
get get all delete save update that's
all if i want to write my own custom
methods then
this link provides us the way to create
them and this is one example to create
them okay there is
let's say as an user i want to search an
employee by the first name how can i do
that just provide this information
that's it
okay and if i say
get find by email id okay this is
actually not present but i want to get
this as a uh
separate method if i want that how can i
fetch it i can definitely fetch it here
so this is how you can write your own
custom methods in the repository right
on top of whatever methods we have
now i will move on to
employee service impl okay this is
implementation of employee service okay
here i have mentioned some of the
methods i have
i tried to make all thread operations
here i have one create method that's
save employee which will take a employee
object and saves it and i have four
methods which will talk about getting
all the employees employ my full name
that is what i've given in my case here
the
repository
okay and other two we have is
get employed by email id and the last
one is my actual id right these are the
four read operations i'll be having in
the employee service and i have other
two methods called as update and delete
methods
okay
so these are the uh five like i try to
cover all credit operations so that you
will feel that this session is not just
about
marketing webinar this would look like
more of a knowledgeable session what i'm
gonna teach in class regularly i'm gonna
tell you telling you guys okay so this
is the service and for the sake for the
same thing i've written all the
implementation over here okay how do i
save an employee it's very simple by
using the repository and i'm saving it
here and also i have get employees
wherein i just write find all get all
the employees and i get my id
get by name like that this
implementation have written we will
discuss then in actual classes when we
have
so and then moving on i have the
employee controller here are the ones
where i've exposed the contents to the
outside world right
so
okay so and i have the post mapping here
which is used to save the employee i
have get mapping here to get all the
employees
i have get my id here to get all the
employees by id i have employees for
email id search the employees by first
name and last name id
i have every possible thing whatever
required for a cloud operation i have
exposed the methods right
so now i think all these things let's
test the back end is working fine or not
okay that's first thing
can i check
rug vendor can i check one thing um we
had a question
which file are you in into which file
are you entering the db configuration
details
which database
what's the username
what's the password and everything will
be putting in this
profile called as application of
properties in the springboot
project
all right
so if you see this i have one two three
four five employees okay now i have a
reputation here we'll come to that
little later i have purposefully made
this to delete this later
now let's say i want to search by id i
can say it as three
see it gives me the output
now i want to search by
i would say what other things i have
i have by email let's see that uh email
let me put in the other tab and get all
the employees list
i will say
matthew.aden i'll just put it in here
sorry
and
just take a second passed
i copied and i say email slash email
that i'll be giving here look at this i
got the email address also with the help
of i exposed an api and i have a search
also can pass
first name and last name over here
and the first name how do you do that is
first you have to put question mark
first name equals to
i would say
bishop
and
last name is equals to
and like this
do i have those entries here
first name is
search
okay
this should looks like all this doubt
the question mark first name
what is saying
anyway so even though it gives error
it's okay but my point here is i just uh
maybe some problem might be there i'm
really not sure
we can debug it some other day my point
is i want to show all details to you
that's why i get to integrate many
things here maybe yeah it works maybe
i've given some ram data in the earlier
one here i've given the proper data so
that's how this is how we can work the
work out the different different apis
whatever ex like
exposed here and
delete and other stuff we can't test
here we used to have used postman now
we have made the entire backend ready
the back end is there i have all the
apis exposed you can list some of them
so that you laugh the idea
apis or i would say
endpoints exposed are this is
the first name and last name
this is
email id
is by request
params
first name
last name
and this is of course with email id
and then you obviously have all the
employees
it's all the employees and you also have
employees by
all emps
and my id
and request params here and email id
goes on like this is exposed some of the
apis which we can leverage have you seen
a dummy api which are written in the
back end and now i'm utilizing it now
how can i use it in the front end okay
so i'll show that to you guys
now i've written the angular application
for the same okay because of time
constraint i could not uh like do a lot
of styling here but the purpose is
served i'll show you how i'll explain
the entire project what i've done here i
have certain components called home
employee and page not found and i could
not build anything on the other two but
employee component is full of data okay
how
i have
i employ component in
like view here okay this is been
having information about employee i have
a table where this contains information
about
employee data okay
this is how a page looks like if i
refresh
we won't have anything it's just an
empty page with load employees button
okay
that's all so
i have used some structural directives
to get those data here and for the same
in the
ts file i have an employees object which
will be loaded or which will be filled
the moment i click on this button called
as
show button okay here also i have
implemented smartly using ng if
directive if the length is greater than
zero only then show the table otherwise
show the button the button is here okay
that's what i've done in your
implementation that's why you have been
saying this load employees it is again
use of
it variable concept i used here
in default directive and i also used
your
template variables and with ngls and
other concepts okay and also
interpolation this one
so this is how i have done the structure
this employee page where we can see the
data
and also
i written a service where it gets the
content from back end and the service is
here here we have this load employees
this employs a
employee service is a class where this
contains the the method which will get
the data from the back end okay if you
notice i have this uh
i would say
we get our employees this is the method
i'm using here so it will
the same data whatever i have in this
url i'll be getting
in the
ui how first data is in the
let me show it to you select star from
employee look at that i have all the
data here
and same thing is coming over here
just happened okay
by mistake it got stopped for some
reason let me start it
it it's too difficult to explain
everything in like half an hour or
sometime muscle i'm trying my best
you will be
learning same experience step by step
with all details
in the classes okay i'll be doing
sharing with you know in a while how the
structure goes also this data if i open
here if i click load employees you get
here
this is how this smooth it looks here
right it's an effort to build this end
to end that is what we're gonna learn in
this entire course right
so we'll be building this building this
stuff is an effort it takes
your immense amount of knowledge and
dedication to learn everything piece by
piece and then putting them across as a
single entity that's what we are here
for okay now i'll show you other two
operations let's say i employees i have
four
i get this employee and five is also
repetitive how can i delete this is the
method to delete and say
don't you if you won't pass anybody does
it okay because the delete method say
send
okay
this is a problem because i am using
this course problem we have let me start
it
there is some
cross origin stuff i have to configure
it i have to include lot of things as
this opportunity here because of
shortage of time i skipped that so if i
now run this
this succeeded
if i go here in the back end if i check
now that data got vanished
that's a delete operation i have update
also maybe i'll update the third one how
will i do that
i'll just show it to you
id is four
delete the put
id is four while
let me take this data here
it is where is that this one
i'll exactly put this here and i'll
modify it
i would say
okay like this
notice here in the back end i have
this guy called as
some wrong name i've given i've given
purposefully saying that i i want to
modify it here i say send
it got updated now just check this
got updated
these three
okay ignore it
so these are the things we'll be doing
in classes okay
we'll be taking okay i forgot to pass
the id he passed it three
oh [ __ ]
there is no five called id called three
or five here now it could have been rc
updated i made a mistake that we don't
pass the id over here
all these things
taking care of my new details
passing an id is equally important and
passing right data is also equally
important
how do we take care of all these things
we'll be learning in this entire journey
okay that is what i wanted to show you
guys
this entire project
like i already discussed this was the
agenda
i showed spoken about lms
i also spoke around all the faces
whatever you're gonna learn in this
entire like full stack courses
each and every phase i discussed with
you guys and i've also shown you how an
employee fetch operation starting from
bracket with all crud operations
ending up in the ui
this is what i've shown you the entire
stuff so that it makes you the
completeness knowledge okay today i've
seen something which is very beneficial
okay that's what we're gonna do in class
now i'll talk about some more
information
after every class
we'll be sharing you this
four links
a github link mentioning where this code
will be present
i'm with my name my repository under
feedback link if we make any mistakes if
there aren't room for improvements
a google drive link where if we want to
upload a file which we can't uploading
github
and the community community link let's
say this place happens only only the
weekend what what if i get doubts on the
weekdays you can always come and raise
your concern in the community and we're
always here to help you guys
that's what
will kind of complete the knowledge
sharing session with you guys so this is
how a day-to-day classes will be going
through okay
i will show one one one small demo of
how i will take the classes
for example let's say i'll recently i
wrapped up one of the face and i'll be
this is how i will actually
talk about them for example
this one okay
in every day what happens
what question i have got
these are projects
in this i'll be talking about micro
services i'll be building up on
different micro services
and spring boot projects look at this
how many have created
make sure you understand what is swagger
what is spring boot what is h2
and also different way of dbc template
spring mvc event handling
and also spring security okay all these
things i'll be teaching in the classes
this will give you a glimpse of how a
day would look like in the classes okay
this one i also covered a small example
of this one say this
also covered as part of this face
because i felt this is very useful okay
the topics i covered in the classes
everything starting from an anonymous
this is an extra thing i covered because
i felt it is useful as an extra thing
okay this is not covered in the face so
as a developer if i feel something needs
to be added is not there in the syllabus
i will make sure that also will also be
added in the
the courses okay
so these are the benefits you're gonna
get if you sign up to this particular
course
i think i'm done from my site stewart
you can take it forward from here on
okay thank you rivenda um
so
we're gonna go to the question and
answers
we have a number of questions that have
come in
and some are technical and some are
about the
administration of the course
so just to be clear
what we've been doing today is a
demonstration of
the
full stack
java developer program
and
revendra has demonstrated
a sample lesson within that and we hope
in future that we'll
do a couple more sample lessons over
time that will
show how you build out from
that basic
data retrieval
example into a
more complete application but the actual
courses that he's talking about are part
of the
full stack uh java developer
program and we'll mention that a little
bit later um he did we did have a
question about that um
we're
uh
i'm just trying to see
ah
cyan actually is in that program
cyan says lesson five is optional and
he saw that it's not covered in live
classes so how are
the materials that are not covered in
live classes
made available to students
and in the sense uh i couldn't
understand the questions to what if you
can repeat that
sure
uh cyan asks a question about
one of his lessons in the
full stack java developer program
which now shows up as optional
so he was curious
how do you cover material how does the
courts cover material
that isn't part of live classes
see
if there is optional again it is up to
you to choose but
if you have any questions on that which
we want you you need let's say
in every phase for phase right we don't
have simple only one project we will
have at least two to three projects okay
and what we'll do is we will ask you to
only write one other or always optional
that doesn't mean that that doesn't stop
you to do that project also
we will make sure that will help you to
build that project if you have any
doubts in those two projects we will be
giving you enough materials to work on
it and let's say even after that you're
still having doubts we'll also help you
to make sure to complete the project
also if you're interested in the other
one or other two if you want to free of
finish all the three
you're good to go
like that
well amir dunn asks uh
he's got a mask macbook pro um
m1 model
even
when i have m1 pro it's absolutely fine
for java development
okay
perfect
um and naman
asks about the class schedules you
mentioned it's a weekend cohort
usually
yes
so we'll be having on the weekends
saturday sunday for four hours each
okay
um so
anaminka had a technical question about
you know the market and the state of the
market
um have angular and react.js really
uprooted html and css or do they
co-exist
see uh this is always a question for
anyone who's starting their career in
this web development right
do we choose react do we choose angular
the question always stays upon i would
say react as a library angular framework
because
react comes with
very very minimalistic thing we have to
build on top of it like let's say a
routing it's not there in react you have
to add an add an ad like add-on on it
it's an advantage because if we have a
free hand to choose whatever we want
from which library is good but
if you need to keep on adding certain
things in angular it's a by default
option for you angular framework itself
provide those features for you and
two-way communication or two to two-way
that is by default there in angular you
have to build it in react so react is
also a good library but angular is also
a very famous library and it is
supported by google and it is also a
very strong and popular library and you
can use it without any second thought so
and
also in the courses in the phase four of
the course i'll be first teaching you
guys html css javascript typescript only
then i'll start angular right that's how
i take the course
right because they're all building
blocks of the
development
yes
um
so
harna asks about
sample applications on github and you
had shown some of the resources
so does that include cutting examples um
you know the types of uh source code
that you've developed in the in the
um classes and that type of thing
see generally i would i lost not boost
about my classes
in my classes whatever i teach
i am not gonna write the code pre-return
whatever code i'm gonna teach i will
write in front of you guys everything
i will even if i make mistakes it's a
lesson for you also me also right so
both we i will make sure that how to
start coding and you can also go along
with me if you are like able to pick up
my page otherwise you can follow and
watch the recording later
and after the end of every session i
will make sure whatever code i write i
will update in a github and also i'll
put it in a google drive if it is
required that's how generally i will
drive my classes
i'm going to address a couple of
questions
jayla asks for example
um
how did how does somebody learn some
basics of coding if they're not ready to
take
a course of this type and i want to just
mention that
simplylearn offers a number of courses
including
free courses through skillup
which is the name of our pre-course
program for
basic
self-study courses
so there are some resources there that
will help you
get
a basic start in coding but um
is is
what are the kind of prerequisites
somebody needs to have in order to
enroll in the full stack
java developer
of course
okay i would see
free courses are always there okay even
if you go to youtube right you you find
a bunch of videos
you want your bunch of materials to read
upon
why do we need us
that's a simple question i'll answer
here which will answer all the questions
okay we know the resources we know what
are there but do we know how to take it
we don't know that's the problem
actually here we are trying to address
we will
make you make sure that you follow our
right path to assimilate those data in
right sequence in right amount okay
that's that's what this this entire
course drives you and we'll make sure
how to take up those things and take
forward right
that's that's that's what we're gonna do
here and that's where this materials
this knowledge sharing and also keep in
mind
when i teach i bring in my own
experience i'm working in one of the top
10 undertake companies like fortune 100
companies so i bring in my experience
also what problems i face in my
day-to-day activities i will be keep
sharing with you those so that's the
knowledge which you will get by default
because i will be teaching you the guys
i'll be taking these courses so these
are the package you get because i'm in
industry for nine years i know how
things works what are the things you
have to focus on where your pain points
will be i'll be telling you guys to work
on them
so it's a package of things you'll be
offered in this program
right
free courses can only take you so far
they're
great for getting some kind of
general idea of how things work but
if you want to go from zero to a full
stack developer
um
that would be a really really difficult
path
if you were trying to do it on your own
and as
rock vendor just said you don't have to
do it on your own you can take advantage
of experience of
him instructors like him
and the way we have structured this
program
um one of the other things that people
have asked about and i will
i think i'll bring up
this
slide here
so allow me to do that
and
talk a little bit about the course
itself
so the whole stack java developer
masters program
that we've been talking about
is six months in duration it's five to
ten hours a week it covers the courses
that
rug vendor showed in the
curriculum
and we designed the curriculum so that
it's aligned with the needs of industry
so that when you want to go into
out looking for a job you will have a
set of skills
that's compatible with what employers
are seeking
as he's shown you that includes
integrated labs and hands-on projects so
what he demonstrated by doing on the
screen is the type of thing that you
will be doing
yourself
to demonstrate that you have an
understanding and the skills to do that
online virtual classrooms which will
allow
you to learn from the instructors and
ask questions in a live environment
where you have your peers to draw on as
well as the instructors and
other than the scheduled classes
which are on a fixed schedule
you can do the work uh for the rest of
the course work on your own
schedule
as you
have time to do it so
it's about a 10 hour a week commitment
for six months and that takes you
all the way through a complete set of
tools libraries
platforms this is just a
sampling of the types of things you'll
learn
um
and at the end
you're certified
by simply learn
you've done
maybe 26
projects and labs in the course of that
six months you've done a capstone
project
which draws together all of those skills
and
gives you something for your github
portfolio
to show off to employers
and i do want to mention that these
programs include job assistance for
learners in india and united states
so
we have different policies for different
regions
in the united states it's a job
assistance program in india it is
actually a job guarantee program through
a number of our industry partners
you can learn more about that
if you go
if you
email ask us at simplylearn.net
i will put that in the chat but in the
meantime
just want to get a quick idea from the
audience of
whether this is something that
interests you
that you'd like to do
and
just a quick pull
as i go into the chat i will put in
okay
put the email address into the chat for
you
and
the learning counselors that ask us at
simplylearn.net will be able to address
questions about
prerequisites about the cost of the
program about
how the job assistance works and
what the different cohorts are
starting dates
and
before i go on to thank you i want to
share with you the poll result
so about 75 of our audience is
interested in doing this
and about 40 of you are interested in
doing it
within the next 90 days so that's great
news um
and let me also share with you another
resource which is
the full stack
java developer
home page put that into the chat
which has additional information about
the program
information about dates and costs
and
with that i want to say thank you to
everybody
i thank you rigvendra
i'm going to
[Music]
give you the link to tomorrow's webinar
if you are interested in digital
marketing or you if you know someone who
is
please feel free to invite them
this will be a
master class for digital marketers uh
specifically in link building for a
successful digital marketing campaign so
that's another
interesting technical class and
with that
we invite you to follow us on our
social media channels at simply learn at
facebook and twitter
simply learn on linkedin
and
again
please do email ask us at
simplylearn.net if you're interested in
finding out more about the program
and thank you greg vendra very much for
taking us through the
lms the learning management system and
also for
uh
demonstrating what it looks like to take
one of the projects live
happy to do that
i mean i wish you all the very much guys
i will tell you make good decisions okay
when i was in out of college right
i struggled a lot to get this whatever i
just educated you just now in the past
one hour those were the things
which was now you guys are privileged to
have it so make good use of it and i
wish you all the very best
see you all there bye guys
all right
and that concludes our
event for today
thank you
you